revista de prensa esta mañana de martes
en directo América de Francia 24 hoy con
el regreso de Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa
bienvenida nuevamente hasta mesa de
trabajo y vamos a hablar de yesira Rosa
Porque llevo el asesinato este medio de
comunicación de su periodista Palestina
estadounidense chirina buakle en el mes
de mayo ante la Corte Penal
Internacional exactamente Raúl hemos
seleccionado precisamente el texto de al
yajira en el que explican esta demanda
dicen que tienen pruebas que contradicen
la versión de Israel de que la
periodista murió en fuego cruzado Y es
que recordemos como bien andrésías la
muerte fue el mes de mayo concretamente
el día 11 mientras la periodista
palestino estadounidense de jazzira
cubría una redada del ejército israelí
en el campo de refugiados de genin en
cisjordania ocupada entonces la versión
israelí es que supuestamente la
periodista habría muerto entre fuego
cruzado entre las tropas de Israel y
combatientes de la resistencia Palestina
sin embargo distintas investigaciones
entre ellas investigaciones de la ONU o
de medios de comunicación independientes
como belling Cat o incluso el New York
Times han señalado han probado como no
había combatientes de la resistencia
Palestina entre el lugar donde se
encontraban los soldados que dispararon
la bala que mató a la periodista y el
lugar donde se encontraban los el grupo
de periodistas entre ellos
identificados con cascos y con chalecos
antibalas donde claramente se podía leer
la palabra prensa no por otro lado
recuerda también este texto que el FBI
también Investiga el supuesto asesinato
sin embargo que Israel No coopera
tampoco con la investigación de las
autoridades estadounidenses y por otro
lado finalmente este medio dice que el
asesinato de sharing se enmarca en una
represión a mayor en unos ataques
constantes de Israel contra al jazira y
contra los periodistas palestinos y el
bombardeo de su sede en gaza en el 15 de
mayo de 2021 finalmente dicen que esta
demanda complementa la interpuesta por
la familia de sirín también ante la
Corte Penal Internacional en el mes de
septiembre y que quieren que se
enmarquen la investigación que ya está
abierta en la Corte Penal Internacional
para investigar precisamente los
crímenes de la ocupación israelí Así es
rosa ahora vamos con las 100 mujeres más
influyentes según la bbc y seleccionamos
10 nombres exactamente y precisamente es
una lista que abre Lina boagle quien es
la sobrina de sheeran y que desde el
principio alzó la voz para que el crimen
contra su tía contra la periodista no
quedará impune pero más allá digamos que
la describe como una activista defensora
de los Derechos Humanos en los
territorios palestinos y también para
citar algunas de las latinoamericanas no
que figuran en esta lista encontramos a
Sandy Cabrera artega quien es defensora
de los derechos reprodu y sexuales en
Honduras un país donde recordemos que el
aborto en todos los casos está penado
con cárcel por otro lado Ceci flores
quienes activista por la búsqueda
desaparecidos forzados en México donde
según la ONU hay más de 100.000 por otro
lado geraldina guerra Garcés activista
contra los feminicidios en Ecuador o
Erika Hilton la primera mujer trans
afrodescendiente en ser elegida al
congreso de Brasil También tenemos a mi
amor y la primera ministra de Barbados
que lideró la transición de ese país de
monarquía a República en 2021 y que ya
el jefe del estado de Barbados no es por
lo tanto El Monarca británico también
encontramos a Salma
la primera mujer que arbitró una un
partido de la Copa africana de Naciones
de fútbol y que es una de las tres
mujeres que arbitra actualmente en el
mundial de fútbol de
Qatar 2022 encontramos también a Liz
patacho activista indígena también de
Brasil yulimar rojas deportista que a ti
exactamente que a ti te gusta medallista
olímpica y también defensora de los
Derechos lgbtq más en Venezuela Úrsula
bonder Legend presidenta de la comisión
o óleonska la primera dama de Ucrania y
solamente para terminar hay muchos
digamos lugares de este ranking dedicado
a mujeres de Irán con nombres y
apellidos sin embargo hay un lugar
reservado en general para la mujer
cortando su pelo en Irán este símbolo
inequívoco de las protestas
antigubernamentales en Irán desatadas
tras la muerte de maxa a Mini y de ese
tema vamos a hablar con nuestro segundo
invitado del día Rosa Muchísimas gracias
mañana con más de revista de prensa